alo chào các bạn
hôm nay rất là sớm hơn mọi hôm bởi vì
cho những nhóm nào mà kiểu
ở nhóm nào muốn chuẩn bị các thứ tinh
thần trước mình mình sẽ mình sẽ mời các
thầy vào tầm 8 giờ hơn cho phát cho các
bạn chuẩn bị trước xong hết đã xong rồi
mình mới mời các thầy vào
nên là nhóm nào muốn diệt qua Vân Vân
thì
Maps cho các nhóm để các nhóm tham gia
tí Mình sẽ gửi lên Google mít cho các
thầy các thầy cũng có thể tham gia phản
biện với các bạn Giá cả còn
thể diệt qua trước
khi mà mình công khai một loạt link cho
tất cả các người khác có thể vào lượng
tiếng lượng người xem cũng có thể sẽ
đông đấy
các bạn cứ chuẩn bị trước đi
Alo
muốn
có thể để mô thử qua nhé cho đỡ giun nhé
cách là thầy phản biện Nhưng mà thực tế
là tôi là người dạy mấy ông nên thành ra
tôi cũng không phản biện gì nhiều mấy mà
chủ yếu do sẽ là các thầy khác sẽ phản
biện các ông chủ yếu cùng ngắm vào thậm
chí ô tô phải nói nâng đỡ trong mấy ông
Nếu giả sử Mấy ông không biết nói
nên là mấy ông cũng không cần phải lo gì
cả nếu hiểu thì tôi không ạ
Mai Hương
không cần bảo vệ duyệt qua
sau đợt bảo vệ này còn nhiều bảo vệ đợt
bảo vệ của các bạn học sau không anh
tương tự giống như Đồ án 1 thì sẽ
thì sẽ kiểu bảo vệ riêng thôi chứ không
có kiểu một buổi livestream bảo vệ chính
thức như thế này nhưng mà nói chung là
như hôm trước tôi có nói là tôi sẽ định
dạy khóa sau nữa để cho nó rất là bài
bản hơn Vân thì chắc là đợt đấy Tôi sẽ
sắp xếp Nếu mà thật sự có đông cũng đông
đông nhóm thì sẽ là kiểu sẽ có một buổi
chính thức kiểu như này và lúc đấy chính
các bạn cũng có thể vào xem lại
gọi là xem
các khóa sau thì nó họ như thế nào cũng
như là kiểu cảm thấy tự hào Khi mình
khóa này gọi tốt nghiệp đúng không
Tôi vẫn thấy cái từ tốt nghiệp nó cứ sai
sai
có người hôm nay bảo với tôi kết thúc
khóa thì tốt nghiệp
mỗi tội là không có cái bằng cấp gì
không có một cái gì ở đây thôi
nhưng mà hôm nay tôi định kêu gọi HR các
thứ thì sẽ có sẽ có tuyển dụng các thứ
thử gọi là mấy ông bảo vệ xong rồi coi
như là có thể thứ hai tuần sau đi làm
để các ông kiểu dạng
Mấy ông có thể thử thử trước thì đỡ giun
cũng được mà
hay tự tin ổn hết rồi
kiểu các ông đều thấy ổn rồi thì thì 8
giờ tôi sẽ gửi link Youtube cho A lĩnh
gửi link YouTube lên các kênh này xong
rồi
nay có mấy nhóm bảo vệ á là tôi chưa
chốt được số lượng nhóm tôi nhắn mấy ông
Nếu giả sử tôi chẳng chốt một cái gì cả
về
[âm nhạc]
ông buông trong ngày hôm nay tôi kiểu cứ
nhắn xong một loạt tất cả nhóm thôi
trước thì sẽ tầm 4 nhóm à tầm 4 đến 5
nhóm gì đó thì họ sẽ kéo dài hơn một
tiếng mỗi nhóm thì thực ra thì hồi mà
tôi chấm cho ở trường thì nó sẽ khắt khe
hơn nó sẽ có bảng điểm và cả là tiêu
chuẩn Mỗi nhóm mình sẽ trình bày trong
vòng bao lâu các thứ thứ tầm 15 20 phút
thôi và trình bày thì các bạn biết được
bố cục trình bày rồi nhỉ Chắc từ đó một
thì biết bố cục trình bày rồi nó vẫn sẽ
tương đương như thế nhờ mỗi tội thêm
nhiều tính năng hơn và trả lời câu hỏi
nó sẽ nhiều hơn nên thành ra là có nghĩa
là mấy ông cứ thoải mái thôi Mỗi nhóm
nửa tiếng cũng được thoải mái
Anh ok ok
cũng sẽ thế nghĩa là mấy ông sẽ đến sớm
để mấy ông demo duyệt qua các thứ thử
trước trước khi bảo vệ chính thức mà
nửa tiếng là còn hơi muộn đấy Bình
thường là đến kiểu trước tầm hơn tiếng
đồng hồ thì ngồi duyệt các thứ đúng
không
nhưng mà tôi thì tôi
mất ngủ từ đêm qua gọi là không Hôm qua
tôi
chiều nay tôi muốn ngủ được một tí còn
tổng cộng Thì hôm qua tôi thức tận 21
tiếng à Nên là kiểu tôi còn run hơn mấy
ông tôi còn suy nghĩ nhiều hơn mấy ông
nhiều
biết mặt mũi gì đâu
chẳng có bằng cấp gì đây
ghi
trong slide có thể tên thật đấy nhưng mà
HR không nhớ đâu
vách tên nếu không cảm thấy
tự ti mình hỏng Mình phải tự tin mình
tốt
chồng mình cả blog và một nhóm đúng
không kiên kiên Hình như là một nhóm nữa
đúng không
bạn kia ở nhóm 7 chưa Bố à ok
xem ai là người Kiểu muốn muốn bảo vệ
đầu đi bảo vệ đầu nó luôn có cái lợi thế
hơn chứ Bây giờ ông bảo vệ sau những
nhóm kia ngon hơn ông tẽm ông hiểu cho
tôi luôn luôn trừ khi ông cảm thấy ông
còn rất là ngon Ông muốn tới phút cuối
anh mới Tỏa Sáng thì ông bảo vệ cuối
nhưng mà nó sẽ có tí nhược điểm khi ông
bảo vệ cuối thì các thầy cô khác cũng
chán rồi chẳng hỏi thì mấy nên thành ra
là ông cũng không được hỏi không không
có cơ hội để mà trình diễn nhiều nên là
một là ông nói chung là ông bảo vệ đầu
nó vẫn có yêu và nhiều Có rất nhiều
nhưng mà thường là bảo vệ đầu ưu nhiều
hơn
là họ sẽ thông cảm ông bảo vệ đầu nếu
ông muốn tỏa sáng thì tỏa sáng được
bảo vệ cuối thì thì
nhiều đâu hết sự câu hỏi rồi cũng như là
cậu các thầy có về cũng chán rồi
tôi có lưu cái kiểu bảo vệ đồ án
tôi và lần thứ ba thì phải bảo vệ cuối
khóa
được giết thời gian rồi còn tận 19 phút
nhưng mà tôi bảo vệ gần tiếng đồng hồ cơ
lâu phết nhá Mấy ông muốn xem qua tuy
nhiên là tôi không nói là nói chung là
hồi đấy tôi xem lại Bây giờ mà xem lại
thì mình cảm thấy bản thân mình có nhiều
vấn đề của anh nhưng mà về cơ bản thì
hồi đấy gọi là gọi là cũng biết cách
biết cách trình bày một tí thôi nhưng mà
mặt công nhận hồi đấy kiêu ngạo thật
Bây giờ tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem qua
có mẹ quay cho
cả
giun là ông chỉ cần là
kiểu
thanh thản ngồi nghĩa những thứ tốt đẹp
đúng không những thứ mà có khi bảo vệ
xong thành công rồi sẽ như thế nào
Ngay Sáng nay tôi cũng vừa đi
đi cùng Nói chung là đi qua
bảo vệ khối khóa xong
đang ở Có khi là tôi phải đăng lại lên
kênh của mình video
tránh bị trôi đi rồi tìm lại mệt quá
ở trong tí
động máy lại thì lại ổn à Ok em
tôi nói trước là cái trình bày của tôi
nó trông nó hơi bị
cái thái độ thì kiểu như thế nhưng mà
tôi làm
tôi làm lại khá là cậu nói chung là khá
là nhiều nên thành ra là tôi
kiểu Trình bày được nhiều thứ cũng như
là
trả lời được câu hỏi các thứ tôi sẽ cho
các bạn xem
Văn Long và bạn cũng định về phát minh
giáo viên hướng dẫn của em là thầy Kiều
Đức Hạnh nhóm em với đề tài là hệ thống
quản lý học viện pkts
thống hiện hành của nhà trường thì vẫn
còn sơ sài và thủ công là hầu như là chỉ
chủ yếu là nhập bằng Word và Excel thì
nên là cần một phần mềm chuyên dụng vì
trường cũng là trường công nghệ thông
tin chính là kiểu Anime áp dụng công
nghệ và để tạo thành nhu cầu ngày càng
lớn của trải nghiệm cũng như là tăng độ
chính xác và hiệu quả khi mà
quản lý sinh viên cũng như nhập liệu
quan trọng nhất đó là giá công việc cho
cán bộ cũng như là tăng độ chính xác và
không tránh tình trạng chậm trễ
viên và giả bộ có thể cập nhật tình
trạng của sinh viên cũng như là tình
trạng giảng dạy của giảng viên
nó luôn lập trình gửi PSP làm cửa bắc Em
tên Quốc
wordp và cơ sở dữ liệu là máy ql
diện với người dùng sẽ thao tác và tương
thích với nhiều kích cỡ màn hình cụ thể
là có thể dùng trên điện thoại về nghiệp
vụ thì là dễ sử dụng cũng như là
chính xác
có những tính năng thì sẽ tự động về bảo
mật thì sẽ yêu cầu bảo mật cao và còn em
có làm là nếu mà đăng nhập sai quá nhiều
lần sẽ có tài khoản về phần cứng thì
cho rằng là thiết bị vào truy cập được
mạng thì
là ngôn ngữ bắt em Facebook 3bl
áp dụng
cả Facebook đút sát làm giao diện và
templet và template chuyên dụng để quản
lý
Ani LP và kết hợp thêm vài thư viện nữa
về cho Switch
các đối tượng sử dụng của em sẽ là giáo
viên giáo vụ kế toán và sinh viên
và đây là đây là Khoa về phần cơ sở dữ
liệu của tính năng bình danh của giáo
viên thì giáo viên sẽ đăng nhập vào điểm
danh
trên phần mềm
Đây là cơ sở dữ liệu về quản lý của tạp
vụ và vụ
rất nhiều cái ví dụ như là chương trình
chương trình đào tạo môn học của sinh
viên giảng viên
và điểm
giáo vụ nhập điểm thực ra nhập điểm thì
không thẳng vào tính năng
Đáng lẽ là nó một tính năng đơn giản
nhưng mà ở bên học viện mình thì nó còn
sợ khác biệt và nó có vụ truyền điện
truyền điện sang K bằng nghề thế nên là
phần mềm sẽ tự động làm việc đấy
nó vụ phân công giảng dạy thì sẽ phân
công cho giáo viên giảng dạy theo lớp và
cho môn khi mà giảm giảm điện đăng nhập
thì sẽ chỉ hiển thị môn và lớp mà mình
đã được phân công
và vào vụ có phương trình Không giảng
dạy nghĩa là sau mỗi tháng giảng viên
điểm danh xong và vũ sẽ tổng kết lại số
giờ mà giảng viên đã giảng dạy trong
tháng đấy để thành công
vào đây là một tính năng nên cảm thấy
hay là lập danh sách thi nó yêu cầu độ
chính xác bởi vì
mình đã nhập phần điểm danh cho sinh
viên rồi thì mình sẽ
lấy được những ai đủ điều kiện để được
chi và thì chị ra Danh sách đề xuất
những bạn nào đã bị trượt
đã bị trượt một ngày của lớp khác hoặc
là những bạn học lại thì sẽ hiển thị ra
đề xuất
chứ không phải là thủ công nhớ
và phần của phần kế toán thì sẽ hiển thị
ra
sẽ có tính năng là kiểm tra xác nhận
thành công của giảng viên giảng viên sẽ
được giám hộ
đầu tiên là giảm bụng sẽ
sẽ làm cái trẻ con để cho giảng viên xác
nhận xem có đúng là tháng rồi đã dạy
người này thì ấm và tiền toàn sẽ vào xem
để mà thành công
này là em làm để cho sinh viên có thể tự
cho quý vị khi mình qua chatbot của
messenger của Facebook Cái này là sinh
viên sẽ nhắn tin cho sutp fanpage nhập
vài thông tin ứng dụng như là mã sinh
viên
tên và số điện thoại để xác thực sinh
viên đấy tôi sẽ hiển thị bảng điểm của
sinh viên đấy
nhân xám em đã có thể đi về vị trí cho
học viện bao gồm những
có là hết em có ghi rõ ở đây không
Ok vừa rồi chỉ nói qua về các bạn thấy
cách trình bày thì
gọi là ở nhà
tôi Tôi Chị Tôi chỉ hi vọng mấy ông tự
tin cũng kiểu na ná được như thế thôi
chứ cũng không
đòi hỏi mấy ông các thứ
cho các thầy nhé người ta thấy tham dự
nha nhóm nhóm Nam muốn bảo vệ đầu tiên
thì mở chia sẻ màn hình rồi
chia sẻ màn hình các thứ thôi
trước
tôi ấn nhầm đợi tôi một tí
Đợi tao một tí nhé
em em cứ đợi đã nha Đợi đợi thêm một
thầy nữa vào xong rồi mình bắt đầu
cứ chia sẻ màn hình đi
Tuấn vào nhưng mà thầy Mạnh Tuấn đang
không biết on hay không
nữa anh nhân lại vừa báo có việc bận rồi
Thôi mình cứ tạm tạm trình bày trước nhỉ
bắt đầu đi
em xin chào thầy và các bạn em là đỗ
khỏe hơn nhóm trưởng của nhóm 4 nhóm
chúng em làm về đề tài là website bán vé
tên là logic tiết kiệm
lý do chúng em chọn đề tài này là với sự
phát triển không ngừng của công nghệ
thông tin truyền thông hiện nay cùng với
nhu cầu di chuyển bằng xe khách rất đang
phổ biến cho nên việc làm mẫu website
cho việc bán vé và đội quản trị doanh
nghiệp
nhà xe là rất cần thiết
khách hàng ở mọi lứa tuổi và nhân viên
quản lý doanh nghiệp
đối tượng của hệ thống chúng em là gồm ở
đây là khách vãng lai passengers
nhân viên nhà xe implorer chủ nhà xe và
admin là quản trị của hệ thống
các bạn like chúng em qua các tính năng
là module đăng ký đăng nhập module Xem
chi tiết chuyến đi module Tìm kiếm lập
sắp xếp chuyến đi và mô đun đặt vé Ngoài
ra còn có Xem vé
tương tự như khách vãng lai và Ngoài ra
có các môđun thoát khỏi đăng nhập thanh
toán PC đánh giá chương đi Xem hủy đơn
vé xe
môđun cũng như bên khách hàng là đăng
nhập đăng xuất module quản lý chuyến đi
module quản lý lịch trình và module
thống kê dân số
tự như nhân viên bán hàng ngoài ra là
còn tính năng quản lý nhân viên bán vé
quản lý xe khách quản lý trong Võ Văn
viết thì có các tính năng là thêm và xóa
amin có quyền quản lý nhà xe quản lý các
bến xe và lập khách hàng
gồm đầu tiên là chúng em lấy thành phần
trung tâm đó là chuyến đi chuyến đi được
tạo từ nhà xe và ở chuyến đi đó nó có
nhiều vé và thuộc một lịch trình nào đó
mà viết được mua
một lịch trình thì sẽ có nhiều bến đó là
nhiều bán được sắp xếp theo thứ tự
về nhà xe thì tuy khách hàng mua để mua
vé thì
đã đi chuyến đi thì có thể đánh giá nhà
xe
nghĩ về các tính năng như liên kết địa
chỉ trên Google Maps giao diện bắt mắt
hơn nhiều hưởng hơn thêm chatbot thêm
trang giới thiệu đăng nhập bằng các tài
khoản khác nhau ở cái này thì em quên
xóa cái này em đã làm rồi
giống như là xôi lạc thể em sẽ nói qua
là bắt đầu Giả sử là khi mà khách hàng
làm tính năng Vậy tính năng là đặt xe
đúng không
đầu tiên là khách hàng làm được những gì
nó sẽ liên quan đến khách hàng là mình
những gì liên quan tính năng nào đúng
không xong rồi những tính năng đấy liên
quan đến em thử nói qua xem
khách hàng có thể đăng ký đăng nhập thì
nó đương nhiên là tác động lên bảng
và khách hàng có thể
tác động lên bản raining bằng cách là
khi đã mua vé và đi chuyến đi thì khách
hàng có thể đánh giá chuyến đi đó và từ
đánh giá dẫn đi đó thì chúng em sẽ
tạo sẽ
tính toán ra một cái chỉ số đánh giá của
nhà xe
chuyến đi thông qua trang chủ
chuyến đi đó thuộc về một nhà xe
và nhà xe có thể có nhiều chuyến đi và
chuyến đi đó cũng thuộc về một lịch
trình lịch trình của nó là lịch trình
của nhà xe
ở lịch trên ở đây thì chúng em có tách
ra một bản nữa là bảng lịch trình chi
tiết bao gồm các thứ tự các bến
nó liên quan đến
[âm nhạc]
với lịch trình đúng không
đến
cái sơ đồ
sao
tại sao em
em lưu lại bảng tua vin suýt làm gì nhỉ
Tại vì khi em lưu trong cái trang web
của em thì em có nhiều cái là em valid
cái địa chỉ của nó luôn ạ Cho nên em lưu
cái địa chỉ là code mã code của
dùng shipper em gọi api đến 1 trang nào
đó và em lấy dữ liệu về em chèn vào bảng
không ạ
xem được là bé này bán hết hay chưa
John với các relation và tính toán với
số vé còn lại số số chỗ ngồi còn lại
tiên thì nhắc luôn thì đó là
slide thường là bảo vệ thì mình sẽ bảo
vệ bằng slide trước sau đó thì mình sẽ
nói qua toàn bộ lý thuyết này trước đây
sẽ gần như là chấm điểm lý thuyết đấy
mình sẽ nói toàn bộ những cái lý thuyết
trước trừ trừ cái slide cuối là slide
hướng mở rộng nhé thì đáng lẽ là cái đấy
sẽ là sau khi demo thì mình mới hiển thị
ra cái hướng mở rộng đấy sau sau slide
này thường là mình sẽ đến demo sau đó
thì em sẽ em sẽ demo các thứ xong rồi
Các thầy có thể đưa câu hỏi ngay trong
lúc đấy để mà chấm điểm thực hành sau đó
thì em có thể quay lại nói nốt về hướng
mở rộng và có thể thêm một vài câu hỏi
nữa
Ok em đi
trang chủ gồm các tuyến phổ biến các vụ
án này là em dùng con api để tính toán
em lấy top 6 chuyên đi phổ biến nhất
chỗ đây thông tin của chuyến đi
nhà xe đánh giá thì em sẽ gọi FBI đến
không render trực tiếp để tránh nặng tốn
thời gian
khi em kết thúc chọn thì nó sẽ chọn
chọn điểm đón và điểm trẻ
Yêu cầu xác nhận
khi thanh toán thành công thì
em sẽ gửi mail
Bằng Kiều
chương VI khi đạt khởi hành
tại là
thường lớn hơn một ngày đến thời gian
khởi hành
chờ này có thể hủy và sẽ có chạy tới chờ
không thể hủy ạ
khách hàng
có thể xem và lọc các user email
ngày Tạo
địa chỉ
xem thêm
các bến xe thì chỉ có nhà xe mới được
thêm
doanh thu trong ngày doanh thu trong
tuần doanh thu trong tháng và số bé đã
bán
cái này thì em có lưu vào các
để khi không cho nhiều với cái đánh giá
này thì em cũng luôn
này
đi và thông tin chuyến đi tổng số vé đã
bán và doanh thu
pdf theo vị trí ngồi là các ví đã đặt
ở đây thì hiện tại chưa có vé nào được
mua cho nên là thông tin này là trống
không
Tại vì lòng gần nhất emsider là hơi lâu
cho nên mấy cái này
em thử mở ẩn danh rồi em thử
người dùng thử vào đặt cái chuyến đi này
trong quá khứ nhưng không thể đặt chuyến
đi trong quá khứ
trong xe ngoài ra là có thể tiếp theo vị
trí đón chào khách nên là các bến
đến đón trẻ
Hiện tại thì em chưa chuẩn bị
[âm nhạc]
mà muốn tìm ở đây thì có thể tải file từ
đây
các danh sách Lịch trình và tìm cái
chuyến đi của nó
Đây là imploid
đặt câu hỏi nhé
được không nhỉ
các số chuyến đi
đã tạo của nhà xe thì nếu mà số nhân đây
nhiều nhất thì cái
lịch trình sẽ được lên
chuyến đi ở bắt buộc đơn phải thành công
đúng không
Hay là em chỉ tính chuyên đi được tạo
thôi à
đặt một chỗ cùng một lúc được cái đó thì
chắc chắn là không được
Tại sao em kiểm tra như nào nếu mà em em
dùng mà trai cách Nếu mà ném lõi thì em
sẽ trả về bên user là
em sẽ hiểu cái thông báo ngay đây là bạn
chưa đặt vé căn vé vé đã được đặt rồi
thông báo kiểu như này
Ừ nhưng mà làm sao mà kiểm tra được em
em kiểm tra tracát
thực hiện quary thì nó sẽ bị đắp liên
kết những cái cây của cái vé kênh của bé
là chip ID và ship vị trí chỗ ngồi Nếu
mà trùng thì nó sẽ báo lỗi thì tất nhiên
khi em trả về bên khách hàng thì em sẽ
hiện thị lực lỗi
tìm tìm lại một chuyến đi anh xem lại
xem
giá tăng dần
loại xe
ok ok chọn thử một cái đánh giá
trên 3 sao trên 4 sao mình có thể đi
được
chỗ
được thì em của cái suy nghĩ đến việc
đến việc xử lý cái này thì em nghĩ là
giới hạn sinh
vào đặt hết nhưng mà chưa thanh toán
em đặt thì trang web
này thì phải thanh toán luôn à thanh
toán thì mới xác nhận là viết đặt hợp lệ
hai người cùng cho vào cùng giỏ hàng
cùng lúc rồi ai thanh toán trước người
ấy được
hàng thì lúc đó em vẫn xử lý kiểm tra là
nếu cái vé đó đã có thì không xác nhận
không Còn bây giờ thì có thể tắm cùng
Đúng không
[âm nhạc]
xe này thì sẽ tốn tiền
nãy nãy thì làm hai người cùng nhận một
chỗ ấy
rồi nhưng mà trùng bạn chắc ID chuyến đi
với cái chỗ trùng bạn báo người ta là
không được thì sao đến cái bước thanh
toán được
là ngay lúc đặt là ai bấm trước là được
chứ
không có đúng không
chỗ này nó sẽ
mới thích cái này là vẫn chưa chưa có
clip này thì đến một trang một người
dùng nào đó thì vẫn thấy là hiện sáng
đèn
đặt không không phải là người khác ở bên
bên trang khác thì nhìn
lại bên admin Hoàng Anh
xem nhiều tiềm năng hơn đúng không
thống kê toàn bộ thôi đúng không
không thể xóa được
Thủy bao nhiêu chuyến không nhỉ
Dạ chưa Tại vì em làm bên khách hàng và
bên admin luôn cho nên em không có thời
gian nhiều để làm những tính năng đó
dạ
Facebook đấy để em xác nhận yêu kiểu gì
biết được là đăng nhập facebook nhỉ
email
định thôi à
filter này thì em làm hoàn toàn bên trên
và gọi api cho nên bên
code Em có khá nhiều
liên quan đến Xóa các thứ mình trong
sáng trông sợ quá
bấm bấm có rồi bay hết thông tin không
nhỉ
xóa
viết là được đặt
không thời gian nó vẫn trường hợp xảy ra
sự em xóa luôn mà khách hàng đang đặt
chưa đặt xong nó lại lỗi Đúng không
không
hướng mở rộng đi
thì
em sẽ liên kết đến địa chỉ Google Maps
để xác nhận thử người dùng đang
đang ở đâu và gợi ý các thông tin
để tìm kiếm chân lý
người dùng có thể xem
cái hành trình của chiếc xe Mình đang đi
từ đâu tới đâu
tương đối hoàn thiện rồi hoàn thiện ở
đây là bài toán về bên khách hàng quản
lý thì cũng một cách tương đối rồi Nhưng
mà thực ra quản lý vẫn còn bổ sung nữa
và các thống kê vừa rồi thì xem Thực ra
nó vẫn mang tính chất ở xem cho vui là
nhiều hơn mình chưa nắm rõ được xem cụ
thể là theo từng chuyến đi hành trình
nào hành trình nào cần ưu tiên các thứ
còn bên admin thì tính năng thì như em
vừa nói nó sẽ vẫn chưa được hoàn thiện
lắm Bên admin đúng không
cũng gọi là hoàn thiện cái một cái đồ án
rồi các thứ rồi
không Cũng có cũng cũng hiểu được là cái
về bài toán là xử lý và xuất ra rồi
nghĩa là xuất ở đây bao gồm cả thống kê
và xuất ra file các thứ thử khá ổn
lại thích thì thích hợp thêm mấy cái
tính năng gửi Mail nữa chẳng hạn cũng
được
Em cảm ơn các thầy và các bạn đã lắng
nghe
thầy các Thành Long và thầy xuân đến với
bài bảo vệ đồ án của nhóm em nhóm em là
nhóm
gồm hai người và
làm từ tháng 5 đến tháng 9 năm 2022 làm
về chủ đề quyết đặt vé xe
thành viên trong nhóm gồm em Nguyễn Tấn
Dũng và bạn Nguyễn Minh Châu
do chọn đề tài công nghệ áp dụng đối
tượng để một trang web và hứng mở rộng
đầu tiên đến với lý do chọn đề tài
vì em thấy nhà xe chưa có trang web đặt
xe về xe online cũng như nhu cầu đặt vé
xe của nhà xe đặt vé xe online ngày càng
tăng
nhẹ và nhà xe cần một trang web quản lý
tiếp theo là các công nghệ em đã áp dụng
7.14.9
atm5
css3
mysql 5.7
và phiên bản larabelle 8 là 3.11
hàng nhân viên và quản lý
khách hàng thì có thể xem các tuyến xe
của nhà xe đặt vé xe trên các tuyến xe
kiểm tra vé xe
nhân viên bao gồm Đăng nhập đăng xuất
quên mật khẩu quản lý thông tin cá nhân
tìm kiếm các chuyến tuyến xe quản lý vé
xe Xem thông tin khách hàng và xem doanh
thu của nhà xe
quản lý sự bao gồm đầy đủ chức năng của
nhân viên quản lý nhân viên quản lý
khách hàng và quản lý tuyến xe
Trần ạ Anh cảm ơn xem
em xin chào thầy và các bạn thì tiếp
theo và em xin Tới phần sơ đồ thực thể
là vì khách hàng thực hiện chuyến đi của
mình từ thành phố A từ thành phố b cho
nên là sẽ có các thực thể như là thành
phố city rapper là tuyến đường càri là
xe và bus là chuyến xe và Khách hàng
muốn đặt chỗ và trả phí cho chuyến đi
của mình thì
vậy nên sẽ có các thực thể như là tiết
kiệm là vé xe và Bill là hóa đơn và
customer là thực hiện khách hàng ở ngoài
ra còn có thực thể như là user
để lưu người dùng admin và nhân viên
tiếp theo thì em xin nói tới phần mối
liên hệ giữa các thực thể thì mối liên
hệ giữa thành phố và tuyến đường là một
thành phố sẽ có nhiều tuyến đường và một
tuyến đường sẽ có
một tuyến đường sẽ có một thành phố bắt
đầu và thành phố kết thúc mà thôi
mối quan hệ giữa tuyến đường và xe thì
một tuyến đường sẽ có nhiều xe chạy ở
trên đó và một xe sẽ chạy trên nhiều
tuyến đường Hệ thống Nhưng mà thực tế hệ
thống của em sẽ chạy trên 2 tuyến đường
là tuyến đường đi và tuyến đường về thôi
Nhưng mà bản chất là
xoay nhiều như là bệnh nên là mối quan
hệ của nó vẫn là ln
tiếp theo Mối quan hệ là của
tuyến đường và tuyến xe thì một tuyến
đường
sẽ có nhiều chuyến xe và một chuyến xe
chỉ có một tuyến đường tương tự với xe
thì một xe sẽ thực hiện nhiều chuyến xe
và một chiếc xe chỉ được thực hiện bởi
một xe thôi Cái đấy là mối quan hệ giữa
chuyến xe và vé xe thì một chiếc xe sẽ
tạo nhiều vết xe và một cái xe sẽ được
tạo bởi một chuyến xe
mối quan hệ giữa vé xe và hóa đơn thì
một cái xe sẽ ở trong sẽ chỉ ở trong một
hóa đơn và
một hóa đơn sẽ có có thể có nhiều cái xe
có thể coi
thực thể về xe này là mối quan hệ giữa
chuyến xe và hóa đơn Bởi vì khi
chiếc xe được sinh ra thì chiếc xe sinh
ra và hóa đơn sinh ra thì khi đó vé xe
mới được sinh ra
tiếp đến là mối quan hệ giữa khách hàng
và hóa đơn thì một khách hàng sẽ có thể
có nhiều hóa đơn và một hóa đơn sẽ chỉ
có được đặt hàng được đặt bởi một khách
hàng thôi
bay
thì
đã tới đây đầu tiên là cái bảng thành
phố là dùng để lưu thông tin thành phố
bao gồm tên phải đi tiếp đến là bạn
router là bạn tuyến đường thì trong này
sẽ có
hai hai cột là Citi task start ID và
dnid
nó là thành phố bắt đầu và thành phố kết
thúc và đương nhiên hai cái này là khóa
chính
Ngoài ra còn có cột nêm
time is stand và image tiếp theo là bạn
karius là bạn sẽ thì mà xe này có chưa
cột lại live
em lấy cái cột này làm khóa chính là
biển số xe thì tiếp theo có các cột như
là ktcori loại xe loại ghế ngồi và số
ghế số ghế mặc định ngoài đây em còn có
thêm màu thì sẽ để dễ phân biệt ở trong
mà trong cái lịch lịch của mình
tiếp đến là bạn router driver với k
router driver K thì bản này sẽ lưu thông
tin ID của
rotter driver và Karis là xe tuyến đường
và
bác tài tài xế thì
bản này còn lưu thêm thông tin giá theo
theo tuyến đường và thiếu xe nữa
kế đến là bạn chuyến xe
giá
em đang ngồi Liệt kê lại tất cả các bạn
anh bảo rồi Em phải nói theo tính năng
ấy tính năng tính năng nào liên quan đến
những bảng nào sau em mới nói ok ở đây
chứ nếu không thì về cơ bản thì ở đây
nhìn rõ được tất cả các cột rồi
[âm nhạc]
Để anh hỏi nhé ờ
Tại sao có cuộc Bill ở trong à quên
tại sao lưu thế nhỉ Mình mình tính toán
được theo
dựa theo bưu điện theo ra được tổng tiền
mà Tại sao phải lưu lại nhỉ
chắc em làm hơi dư cột này
có thể là đúng là
lưu được theo đúng là tính toán được
theo bidtee Nhưng mà em này thêm cột này
có thể là hơi dư
thiết kế ra bây nó có lý do nó cả không
Chứ chứ bà em không biết lưu để làm gì
thì chết tiếp theo Tại sao có cột Prime
ở trong Build đi theo
rai ở trong video để lưu
lưu giá của
đôi dép của chuyến đi chuyến đi Tại thời
gian đâu
với số lượng sau
nào khác gì nhau
nhà thực tế Nó là một ở anh chẳng có Tại
vì lúc đó tùy em làm theo Bi đi theo
nhưng mà sau này xin xin ra thêm cái vé
từ thịt nhưng mà
giống em chưa kịp tổng lại
nhưng mà bản chất nó vẫn là kết nối 11
nên là thực tế cái database không không
hề sai
đây số lượng nhiều
thông tin của anh khách Một hành khách
mà có nhiều số lượng một vé
nhìn số lượng ghê cái này là em qua li
ti này em đếm theo số lượng của slot
hành khách ngồi một phát bao Buồn ghê á
Dạ không Cái này là em làm theo customer
là một khách hàng khách hàng có thể đặt
nhiều
nhiều chỗ cho nhiều hành khách
Đúng rồi nhưng mà ý anh là cái cái bên
tích cực ấy em đang ngồi sang cái Bill
thêu Nếu mà em bảo là 11 thì tức là là
một thằng passinger
Đúng rồi
phải sinh có bao nhiêu ghế em sinh ra
bấy nhiêu vé xong rồi mới về thông tin
cái cột contit
ghế xong một vé đấy lại có thông tin của
một khách thôi Khá là bảo một khách ngồi
luôn ba ghế đúng không em
ok
vào Hải Yến vào
bạn để HR với it Nhưng mà thực ra không
quan tâm bạn ấy biết về it hay không mà
sẽ là một người kiểu dạng là một người
không biết về công nghệ càng tốt để mà
sẽ hỏi các bạn và các bạn mà trả lời
thuyết trình sao cho người không phải
dân công nghệ cũng hiểu được thì mới
thành công
các thầy mà hỏi công nghệ rồi các bạn
trả lời Công nghệ thì nó lại quá bình
thường rồi nên là
tí bạn ấy sẽ đưa một loạt câu hỏi các
thứ
gì không
tiết kiệm nó có nói với cái sảnh với
city Á trong khi quyết định này mình sẽ
hiện cái rau này là được rồi
về li địa chỉ cho khách hàng và Vừa lưu
địa chỉ cho thành phố
[âm nhạc]
địa chỉ của khách hàng
địa chỉ khách hàng này địa chỉ lúc đặt
vé à Hay là lúc nào Dạ đúng rồi lúc đặc
biệt thì khách hàng có địa chỉ địa chỉ
đón thì
lưu cột giá nhiều quá
không hiểu lắm giá của router driver là
nó định giá theo tuyến đường Và xe còn
giá của bớt là em đang giá theo
giá theo cái tuyến đường này với lại giá
theo cái thời gian thực khi cái thời
gian tạo khi đó có nghĩa là
giá ở tháng trước sẽ khác với giá ở
tháng này ở cùng tuyến đường và Hùng xe
cho nên em sẽ lưu giá ở đấy
giá của chiếc xe nó
đã
em xin
nhiều bạn
Dũng demo khách hàng
Trần phổ biến và
vé xe đó là chọn theo lộ trình phổ biến
ở dưới này và
chọn theo nơi đi đến ở trên này
đường
các tuyến của nhà xe hiện có
điểm đến
qua trang
ở đây khách hàng chỉ được chọn những
ngày trong tương lai và sẽ không chọn
được ở Quá Khứ
trình sẽ có Future theo giá từ thấp đến
cao hoặc cao đẳng thấp theo loại ghế và
theo lại giờ
ghế khi
nhân
thông báo đặt vé và sẽ có gửi mail về về
Gmail sẽ có thông tin này
thể kiểm kiểm tra vé theo mã vé và số
điện thoại
Các thầy có câu hỏi gì không ạ
xếp xếp của em anh vào
sếp của anh là anh Hải anh ấy giám đốc
điều hành ở bên anh Và chắc là anh ấy sẽ
phản biện các bạn luôn anh Hải có
muốn hỏi thêm gì em được không ạ
cũng mới vào thì cũng chưa gặp được
thông tin cụ thể thì mọi người cứ Trình
bày đi thì còn
anh nếu mà có câu hỏi gì thì anh sẽ hỏi
sau nhé Hiện tại thì anh thấy cũng chưa
có câu hỏi gì cả
tuần này mới chỉ dành cho khách hàng
đúng không
Khách hàng đã đặt vé số lượng tài xế của
nhà xe số lượng xe và doanh thu trong
một năm
vé xem nhiều nhất và các tuyến phổ biến
tiếp theo là sẽ có phần doanh thu
theo 30 ngày hoặc 12 tháng
số điện thoại và mẹ bé của khách hàng
và có thể filter ngay trên anh tiêu đề
về xe và tình trạng thanh toán
hiện tại em chưa sử dụng tích hợp được
thanh toán online nên sẽ sử dụng tay sau
khi thanh toán thì mình có thể thay đổi
tình trạng thanh toán và nếu như khách
hàng có nhập sai thì mình có thể chỉnh
được tên khách hàng số điện thoại cũng
như email và số lượng ghế
cũng như điểm đó đó và cách thanh toán
quản lý tuyến đường thì sẽ filter theo
tên điểm đi điểm đến và điểm về
thông tin của xe và tài xế
các phần còn lại em để cho bạn thuyết
trình tiếp
quản lý chuyến xe thì trong này em em là
một cái lịch trình để quản lý chuyến xe
của mình thì quản lý chuyến xe sẽ quản
lý theo tuyến đường mình sẽ chọn tuyến
đường ở đây
và
để em xin
cái này nó chưa
đầu tiên là nó sẽ chọn tuyến đường
và sẽ hiện lên các chuyến xe ở trong
lịch trình này thì khi mà ấn vào trong
chuyến xe thì có thể xem các thông tin
của xe tài xế thời gian thời gian bắt
đầu và giá của nó và có thể kiểm tra
được các chỗ đã đặt
và có thể sửa xóa
cái phần này thì không
đây mình có thể sửa biển số xe loại xe
loại ghế thì cũng như xui xốp ghế và giá
sửa luôn và mình có thể sửa phần màu ở
trong lịch thuyền này có thể cho dễ nhìn
Ví dụ em sửa cái phần cái biển cái xe có
biển số xe là 7v này
thì khi sửa xong thì ở trong lịch trình
có thể đổi màu cho cho dễ nhìn hơn và ở
trong hành trình này có thể thêm thêm xe
của mình thêm xe
và có thể kéo thả kéo thả xe này vào và
nó sẽ hiện luôn hiện lên thông tin xe và
tài xế Đồng thời hiện luôn giá và cả
ngày mình kéo thả vào
để có thể tạo và em kiểm tra
tiếp theo là về phần Tảo Kiên xe thì có
thể
tạo chiếc xe ở đây và em có kiểm tra là
xe chuyến xe này không thể tạo trước cái
ngày trước ngày hôm nay và
[âm nhạc]
em có
Khi mà đang ở trên
đang đang trong thời gian di chuyển hoặc
là sẽ không thể tạo ở khi mà xe nó đang
ở bên tuyến đường ngược lại
là tạo nhân
thì em bảo bảo nhắn hàng loạt và
tạo theo tuần
tôi 41
thúc và ở tuần 41 luôn thì nó sẽ hiện
ngày bắt đầu và ngày kết thúc cho mình
và
chọn thời gian khoảng thời gian mà giữa
hai chuyến xe được tạo
mình có thể chọn ở đây
và thời gian bắt đầu trong ngày thời
gian bắt đầu của chuyến xe đó
Bạn sẽ chọn phần 6 giờ và thời gian kết
thúc và chuyến xe đó tạo
em sẽ chọn 6 giờ luôn
tiếp theo là chọn phần thông tin tuyến
đường được tạo thì em sẽ chọn tuyến
đường đầu tiên và nó sẽ load luôn cái
phần tuyến ngược lại cho mình đồng thời
là nó lót luôn phần thời gian di chuyển
và khoảng cách Kế đến thì mình sẽ kiểm
tra xe để xem cái các xe đó Nó đang ở
phía nào
và hiển thị lên luôn cho mình thì
nó kiểm tra vào thứ 7 này và
nó kiểm tra xem là các xe đang ở
tuyến đường nào vào ngày thứ bảy
tiếp theo là anh tàn nhẫn thì nó sẽ tạo
hàng loạt cho mình và nó sẽ
quay lại trang lịch trình
hiện lên những chuyến đi xe mới cho mình
trình bày phần Xóa nhanh
đường và xóa theo cái tuần thì em chọn
tuyến đường
tuyến đường đầu tiên và nó sẽ là phần
tuyến đường về và em sẽ xóa cái tuần hồi
nãy em đã tạo
thì khi xóa nó sẽ trở về lại trang lịch
trình Ủa tại sao lại cần tính năng xóa
nhanh ở nhà
Tại vì khi xóa nhãn của mình Tại vì khi
mình tạo nhanh tạo nhánh trên xe thì sẽ
có lỗi ở trong đó khi mình kiểm tra xe
này có phần mình không muốn thì mình sẽ
xóa nhanh để phục vụ cho việc tạo nhánh
này thôi có tin là sao Nhắn để phục vụ
cho việc tạo nhanh còn em chưa giới hạn
cái phần sa nhân này cho
việc sát nhân ở Quá Khứ
tuyến đường ở quá khứ
tiếp theo là
sang trang danh sách
thì tránh nhận xét này sẽ hiện lên các
chính sách chuyên đi của mình thì tương
tự như quản lý vé xe và quản lý thiên
đường thì sẽ có filter và hiện lên các
thông tin có thể edit và xóa nó
tiếp theo thì em sẽ qua phần quản lý xe
thì quản lý xe sẽ có hiện lên các thông
tin của xe tương tự tương tự như các
phần quản lý y trên quản lý danh sách
đầu tiên có thêm xe mới
và quản lý nhân viên
thì sẽ có
và có thể ấn vào số điện thoại hoặc là
email để kết nối với người
với chủ sở hữu
cái đấy là quản lý khách hàng thì Vào
phần xem khách hàng thì sẽ có thông tin
khách hàng đó ở Phần này em ở chưa chưa
Tạo phần quản Xem hóa đơn của khách hàng
này
em xin kết thúc cái phần trình bày
demo trang web
anh có câu hỏi là cái phần quản lý xe
này mình có thể xem lịch trình của một
xe được không Ví dụ xem là xe đấy thì
trong tuần này tháng này thì nó có những
cái đỉnh lịch trình như nào ấy
dạ phần đó gặp em đang làm cho hướng mở
rộng mà nhóm Em chưa làm
thường là sẽ lên lịch theo theo từng xe
nghĩa là bây giờ xe thì anh thấy là đa
phần các xe nó sẽ có một lịch trình cố
định theo tuần Đấy ví dụ là
[âm nhạc]
các tuyến mà tuyến ngắn thì ví dụ là
Theo lịch trình nó cứ 8 giờ sáng hàng
ngày là xuất phát ví dụ là từ Hà Nội đi
Ninh Bình à Thế xong rồi 2 giờ chiều là
xuất phát quay ngược trở lại từ Ninh
Bình về Hà Nội thì mình có thể lên một
cái lịch tự động cho một cái cái xe được
không Nghĩa là mình đặt thì cứ đến đến
hàng tuần thì sẽ tự động tạo các chuyến
xe theo một cái lịch trình cố định như
vậy
Dạ về cố định thì về phần cố định thì
nhóm em có thể hoàn toàn làm được tại vì
cái phần tàn nhẫn này là phần tạo nhân
demo thôi chưa up không không có áp dụng
vào thực tế thì
biểu hiện cho việc là có thể tạo nhân
tạo nhân chuyên xe bằng những thông tin
mà nhà xe yêu cầu thì nhóm em sẽ có thể
liên lạc với ở nhà sẽ để
để tạo tạo các cái thêm nhân riêng cho
từng cho từng tuyến đường Ví dụ như
tuyến đường mà những có những tuyến
đường ngắn với những tuyến đường dài thì
những tuyến đường ngắn sẽ sẽ đi và về ở
trong ngày còn những chuyến đi dài thì
sẽ có thể đi và về ở khác ngày khác ngày
nhau khác nhau cho nên là cái phần này
em chỉ là demo thôi Thực tế thì phải
liên hệ với nhà xe để tạo riêng cho từng
tuyến đường
anh thấy là cái phần tạo nhanh này thì
cơ bản là hỗ trợ để để mình quản lý
nhưng mà anh thấy là nếu như mà làm được
theo cái tiếng Việt mà mình đặt lịch
theo xe và hệ thống sẽ tự tạo cái các
chuyến xe thì anh thấy nó sẽ tiết kiệm
thời gian hơn bởi vì thường này cái lịch
trình của xe nó sẽ cố định mà ta cứ chỉ
chạy đi chạy về thôi thì ví dụ như là
những tuyến dài Ví dụ mất hai đến ba
ngày thì sau khi tự từ Hà Nội Sài Gòn
mất hai ngày chẳng hạn thế Thì là sau
khi ra Hà Nội thì có thể là nghỉ một
ngày sau đó lại quay lại thì là cái lịch
lịch trình của xe là nó cứ lặp đi lặp
lại như vậy thì nếu mình tạo ra một cái
lịch trình cho cho từng xe và sau đó thì
hệ thống sẽ tự động tạo ra các chuyến xe
tương ứng thì anh thấy là nó sẽ sẽ hợp
lý hơn Còn khi nào lịch trình của xe có
sự thay đổi đề thi những người quản lý
Mình chỉ cần cập nhật lại lịch trình của
xe thôi còn các chuyến xe là sẽ được tận
được tạo tự động dựa trên lịch trình xe
đấy tiếng tiết kiệm một thời gian hơn
bởi vì cái này thì gần như là tuần nào
cũng sẽ phải có người để để tạo lịch
trình cho các cho từng xe từng tuyến
đúng không
với số lượng xe và số lượng tuyến lớn
thì anh anh nghĩ là cái phần này nó khá
mất thời gian Đây này cái người quản trị
là bây giờ hàng ngày sẽ phải vào để cập
nhật tạo các chuyến xe dựa trên
các cái lịch lộ trình rồi là theo các
đầu xe khác nhau thì anh nghĩ cái công
việc này nó khá mất thời gian thì nếu
như mình có một cái tính năng để hỗ trợ
là mình sẽ quản lý cái lịch trình cho
từng xe và hệ thống sẽ tự động tạo các
chuyến xe thì anh nghĩ là nó sẽ sẽ tối
ưu hơn về cái mặt quản lý
Nhà em Cảm ơn em Cảm ơn anh
bây giờ mình mình muốn đặt gấp một
chuyến đi thì vẫn phải đặt quá đúng
không Ví dụ trong tối nay mình cần đi
luôn đấy
mình phải đặt qua cái hệ thống của xe
đạt cấp thì
nhóm em chưa chưa
chưa xem cái cái phần này khi bạn đấy
thì kiểu như này nó kiểu bây giờ là ví
dụ lên trang của em thì người dùng thể
thao tác nữa thử mất công đúng không Thế
bây giờ nếu mà cùng giao diện ở bên
admin em phải đặt nhanh cho bạn ấy một
cái xong rồi Kiểu bạn ấy chuyển khoản
một phát coi như đơn đường Duyệt luôn
chẳng hạn thì nó tiện hơn với việc làm
nhiều thao tác ở trên trang em đúng
không
anh Dạ gặp em chưa chưa làm phần đó em
tính làm tích hợp vào trong ở trong cái
lịch trình này luôn thì khi gọi điện thì
admin hoặc là nhân viên có thể có thể
điền thông tin ngay tại ở trên cái
Chuyến Xe này và xác nhận luôn cho khách
hàng của mình là vé đã được đặt
Ờ anh quay quay lại bên quản lý nhân
viên Anh xem gì
em quản lý nhân viên
Thực ra quản lý thông tin này mới chỉ
còn quản lý nhân viên mới chỉ quản lý
thông tin thôi nhỉ chưa có một cái gì
gọi là quản lý ở đây lắm nhỉ
Dạ có xem thêm sữa cho hắn không Thì đấy
vẫn là còn quản lý thông tin thôi À đúng
rồi
về quản lý nhân viên thì có lọc chức vụ
như bác tài nhân viên quản lý thì vị trí
là như thế
vị trí là là vị trí là
địa chỉ đúng rồi vị trí là chị địa chỉ
không Mình phải lọc lọc keo chuyến xe
hay lọc theo cái gì đó chứ Dạ bây giờ
Giả sử anh muốn biết được toàn bộ nhân
viên của một cái chuyến xe nào đó Bởi vì
chuyến xe đấy bị kiến nghị bị khiếu nại
chẳng hạn thì anh tìm như nào nhỉ
em Em chưa làm phần này
năng xem thêm sửa xóa cơ bản thôi đúng
không
Bởi vì nó vẫn chưa Chưa có cái gì cả
đúng không Nói chung là cái web của em
thì vẫn đang làm ổn ít nhất là quản lý
vé xe quản lý chuyến xe rồi Nhưng mà
đúng là nó vẫn hơn một tí thủ công Tuy
là có cái Tín cái tạo nhanh của em nhưng
mà nó vẫn thủ công và không như anh Hải
góp ý là nó không tự động được nghĩa
thường xuyên Mình vẫn sẽ phải vào cập
nhật đúng không
và cái quản lý nhân viên cả quản lý
khách hàng của em thì nó vẫn chưa có
đúng không nó mình chỉ ở mức cơ bản thôi
ok Còn em em còn muốn
nói thêm những tính năng gì nữa
nhà em xin cảm ơn Dạ
với buổi bảo vệ của nhóm em ngày hôm nay
em là Trần Công Trí hay là broad và nhóm
21 và đã nhóm em làm về quản lý lớp vỏ
tốc Tức là những lớp có quy mô nhỏ
hôm nay phần 1 là những lý do khiến em
chọn đề tài này và hay là những công
nghệ đã sử dụng trong đồ án phần thứ ba
là những đối tượng sử dụng của hệ thống
phần thứ tư là số được thực hiện phần 5
là cơ sở dữ liệu phần 6 là phần demo các
tính năng và phần 7 là hướng mở rộng
phát triển và mở rộng thêm phần 8 là
phần kết luận
sử dụng công nghệ tam cấp lĩnh vực hỗ
trợ cho công việc trở thành một nhu cầu
thiết yếu ứng dụng phổ biến những giá
trị những lợi ích mà công nghệ mang lại
với hệ thống quản lý lớp học hỗ trợ cho
công tác giảng dạy đào tạo và quản lý
kiểm soát học sinh được thực hiện tốt hỗ
trợ cho công việc của từng giảng viên
giáo vụ giáo vụ ngày càng phát triển
giáo dục ngày càng phát triển với các
quy mô ngày một lớn việc quản lý lớp học
xuất hiện nhiều khó khăn và cần một hệ
thống để quản lý lớp học một cách chính
xác và hiệu quả Tuy nhiên hiện nay có
những hệ thống Tuy nhiên tới hiện nay đã
có những hệ thống quản lý lớp học tuy
nhiên vẫn còn nhiều hạn chế
cần phải mở pro hoặc prendium điểm sử
dụng các tính năng thực sự hiệu quả
thứ ba thì bản thân em muốn đóng góp một
phần nhỏ nào đó cho quản lý giáo dục
giúp đỡ một phần nào đó giọng gánh nặng
cho công việc quản lý trường lớp nói
chung và quản lý giáo dục nói riêng thứ
tư thì đồ án này giúp em có thêm những
kinh nghiệm cũng như nâng cao kỹ năng
lập trình của bản thân hiểu sâu hơn về
Framework và các thư viện khác
nhóm em dùng trái tim 7.4
framburger 8 máy SQL
chính là sinh viên giảng viên giáo vụ và
quản trị viên
đối với sinh viên ngày chỉ có những tính
năng chính như là đăng nhập đăng xuất
Xem tổng quan tình hình học tập xem lịch
học lịch sử điểm danh của bản thân Xem
thông tin lớp có xem điểm cá nhân nhập
thông báo của hệ thống lịch cá nhân và
xem thông tin liên hệ nhân viên
ở phía giảng viên Thì
có những tính năng như là đăng nhập xem
thông tin lớp tổng quan tình hình giảng
dạy xem lịch giảng dạy và vào điểm cho
sinh viên điểm danh cho sinh viên nhận
thông báo của hệ thống lịch cá nhân Xem
công ty liên hệ dấu vụ và đăng xuất
ở giáo vụ thì có những tính năng như là
đăng nhập xem nhận xem không tổng quan
tình hình giảng dạy quản lý tài khoản từ
sinh viên đến Giảng viên quản lý lớp học
quản lý điểm cho sinh viên quản lý và
tập trung quản lý điểm danh
thông báo là cá nhân và đăng xuất
ở phía quản trị viên thì cũng tương tự
như dấu vào Tuy nhiên có thể quản lý tài
khoản và dấu vụ
ard của hệ thống lớp học bổ túc
là người dùng lớp học môn học
giữa môn học và người dùng có 21 quan hệ
chính đó chính là sinh viên và giảng
viên và giảng viên có thể học nhiều môn
và một môn được học bởi nhiều sinh viên
nên mới quan hệ là n n
mỗi giảng viên chỉ có thể dạy một môn và
1 mol chỉ có thể dạy bởi các hệ giải bởi
nhiều giảng viên thì mối quan hệ là một
n
Vì Một lớp có nhiều sinh viên và một
sinh viên ở nhiều lớp nên sinh ra quan
hệ lớp sinh viên và điểm mối quan hệ là
n n tìm một lớp chỉ có một giảng viên và
một giảng viên thuộc nhiều lớp nên mối
quan hệ là 1 và N
về một lớp thuộc một môn và 1 mol chỉ 1
môn có nhiều lớp nên mối quan hệ là một
n Vì Một lớp có một lịch học một lịch
học chỉ thuộc một lớp nền mối quan hệ là
một màu
vì lịch học có nhiều học sinh và một học
sinh cũng có thể có nhiều lịch học để
mối quan hệ điểm danh mối quan hệ n
đo có sở dữ liệu
về hệ thống
sinh viên thì sẽ được liên kết với lớp
học qua thông qua báo tham qua bảng
flash student và
người giàu mình có thể nhập thông báo
bạn cũng phải
người dùng có thể về dòng Nếu là sinh
viên thì có thể xem điểm qua bảng score
Và nếu là giảng viên thì có thể tương
tác với bạn sẽ có điểm là giảng viên
hoặc giáo vụ hoặc là quản trị viên thì
có thể tương tác với điểm của sinh viên
qua score
người dùng là giáo vụ giảng viên và quản
trị viên thì có thể tương tác điểm danh
cho sinh viên theo extendant còn sinh
viên thì cũng có thể xem
người dùng
nó sẽ liên kết với bản lịch học
sẽ có một học chữ từ một môn nên nó sẽ
liên kết với lại stress
ở đây Theo anh nhớ thì nó là kiểu em em
tổ chức lớp học kiểu dạng
sinh viên đăng ký xong rồi mở lớp hay là
mở lớp rồi đăng ký nha sinh viên đăng ký
cho giảng viên hoặc là giáo hội giáo hội
sẽ thêm sinh viên đó vào lớp
đăng ký môn học với giảng viên
nghĩa là đầu tiên là có môn học đúng
không Xong rồi em đăng ký đủ lượng sinh
viên thì mới mở lớp đúng không nhỉ
tính năng như lúc đầu anh vừa nói đi đó
là đó là tính năng nếu mà giả sử là sinh
viên đăng ký lớp học thì thông qua những
cái bảng nào và lưu lại những cái gì
sinh viên đăng ký theo đăng ký với giảng
viên Thì chỉ trên lớp thôi và giảng viên
người tổng hợp những cái danh sách đó
vào một file và
chứ chưa có tính năng đăng ký
lại giảng viên Thì giảng viên sẽ có một
file
sinh viên và môn học thì sẽ nó sẽ lưu
vào class student
và nó phân lớp ra là nó
Urê em em đăng ký rồi nó lừa trong user
đúng không sau đó thì
nó mở lớp xong rồi nối giữa sinh viên
vào lớp hay như nào
để phân biệt là giảng viên hay là sinh
viên hay là quản trị viên hay là giáo vụ
bảng
học thì
nó sẽ tổng các điểm bản instant tổng các
điểm thông qua bảng extendant và tổng
kết điểm trên cần sau đó tính điểm cuối
kỳ mỗi sinh viên
và Final thì
giảng viên hoặc là giáo vụ hoặc là quản
trị viên sẽ thêm
anh Hải Bạn Yến có muốn hỏi gì không
đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ nhận được những
thông báo về hệ thống
ở trong tổng quan thì chúng ta sẽ thống
kê các lớp đã và đang học những xua đuổi
đã học và trạng thái là điểm danh
thì ở phần lịch cá nhân thì
sinh viên Lưu ý bên phải thì sẽ có là
thập phần
và giảng viên chúng ta có thể liên hệ
qua Gmail
không để cả số điện thoại để cho sinh
viên dễ gọi hơn thay vì email bởi vì
nhiều
giảng viên có thể
lúc thiết kế ca sĩ giai điệu em chưa bỏ
số điện thoại vào nên nó không liên hệ
theo kiểu số điện thoại
có thể xem được ở đây xin quý khách Xem
tham quan được tên ông buổi họp ca số
ngày đã học ngày kết thúc dự kiến giảng
viên Xem chi tiết thì có thể xem được
các danh sách các bạn ở trong lớp
và email liên hệ để dễ dàng
trao đổi
để phần lịch học thì
sinh viên có thể xem được lịch học của
bản thân theo là tháng tuần tuần và ngày
hiện tại và
điểm danh của
để có trạng thái Ghi chú để cho sinh
viên
xem điểm của mình mỗi khi cập nhật điểm
thì nó sẽ gửi thông báo đến cho sinh
viên
cho nên là
giảng viên
những tính năng như sinh viên nhưng ở
đây là nó sẽ random liên hệ cho giáo vụ
thì thực ra ý em làm random ở đây là để
gọi là giảm bớt cái nạn tại vì nếu chỉ
hiển thị
một theo thứ tự thì sẽ có người làm
nhiều công việc còn có người thì không
làm công việc nào hết
sinh viên thì có thể xem được thông tin
lớp hiện đang giảng dạy
giảng viên có thể điểm danh cho sinh
viên theo các buổi ở đây thì nó có thống
kê
một số thống kê để cho giảng viên dễ
dàng quản lý như là tổng giám đốc sinh
viên trong lớp số học sinh đi học đầy đủ
hoặc là số học sinh đề nghị của 3 buổi
bận cấp danh sách các bộ xs điểm danh
thì
quá khứ
hoặc là có thể có nghĩa là có thể sửa
điểm danh và buổi đó Tại vì trường em
cũng có gọi là có hệ thống điểm danh
nhưng mà giáo viên giảng viên không sử
dụng tại vì nó không thể sửa được
những buổi đã học cho nên là Nếu xét về
Lộc thì nó là đúng nhưng mà chắc là tấn
công người thì
giảng viên vẫn không dùng do không thể
sửa được camera trước cho sinh viên
điểm cho sinh viên vào các môn đang học
đối tượng đó chính là
giáo vụ và quản trị viên
thì ban Giám bảo phần tổng quan thì cũng
tương tự có thể xem được thống kê số
sinh viên giảng viên số lượng lớp cũng
như mong học
hai đối tượng có thể quản lý người dùng
trong Tuy nhiên thì giá bộ thì chỉ có
thể quản lý được sinh viên và giảng viên
thôi còn quản trị viên thì có thể quản
lý được cả giáo vụ nữa
sinh viên chưa đi vào hoạt động và giảng
viên cũng tương tự nghĩa là sinh viên
chưa từng học lớp nào hoặc là giảng viên
chưa từng học lớp nào
có thể sửa thông tin Tổng quan của sinh
viên và giảng viên
công
ở đây thì quản trị viên hệ có thể xem
thêm được sinh viên giảng viên và giáo
vụ Tuy nhiên Giáo phận thì chị có thể
thêm được sinh viên và giảng viên thôi
hiển thị ra file mẫu để cho người dùng
tải về sau đó Chỉnh sửa và upload
sửa thông tin lớp học nếu lớp chưa Nếu
lớp
chưa được phê duyệt Còn nếu phải Duyệt
rồi thì sẽ không thể chỉnh sửa gọi thông
tin của lớp
cái cột status tức là em quy định Nó là
một tức là chơi phê duyệt hay là đã phê
duyệt rồi và ba là đã kết thúc
Em chỉ cần check Cái đó là em có thể
chỉnh sửa
cần hội tụ
nhiều yếu tố ví dụ như là
ví dụ như là đã có giảng viên đã đầy đủ
thông tin có giảng viên và số lượng lớp
trên 15 bạn thì mới có thể tạo lớp
có thể thêm giảng viên Thì ở đây hệ
thống em sẽ hiển thị ra những đoạn giảng
viên mà không có lịch trùng với lại mona
với lại lớp này
là em sinh viên kiểu
đấy có thể lập thông tin
có thể Speed được còn nếu nếu như mà
trao đổi qua thông tin trên thì không
thể phê duyệt được lớp
cái gì thì nó sẽ cho xem thông tin một
lần nữa để xác nhận thông tin của lớp
nó sẽ to cho như em nói lúc nãy thì
giảng viên sẽ tổng hợp các sinh viên mà
đăng ký lớp theo Môn
lớp
ở đây thì lớp lớp 9 Lúc nãy đã đủ rồi
cho nên nó sẽ tạo thêm một lớp 10 lớp
bắn 10 hoặc là lớp
tiếng Anh Lúc nãy đã đủ rồi nên nó sẽ
tạo thêm một lớp tiếng Anh 2 Và tất
nhiên thì trả góp công ty giảng viên
giáo viên
lớp hả em
Mình chưa đủ trên 15 sinh viên thì mình
sẽ không thể mở lớp được
nghĩa là phần này thì nhà trần sẽ quy
định
quyết định ở đâu em nhỉ
cái trường hợp ý Kẻ số lượng cả lớp kia
cũng chỉ có 4 5 người thôi thì thì sẽ
làm thế nào
nó sẽ thêm vô Ví dụ như mình tải lên
file thì nó sẽ tự động thêm vô Nếu lớp
đó đã chưa đủ số lượng
còn nếu là đủ rồi thì nó sẽ thêm một lớp
khác
viên rồi nó vẫn chưa đủ thì không thể
phê duyệt lớp được
tất cả tính năng rồi đúng không
Thì mình có thể xem được thông tin lớp
học như lúc nãy Nhưng mà tao có thể xem
được thêm điểm tổng kết nữa
khai môn học
Xem thông tin môn học như là
có trong môn học số lượng buổi học và
ngài bắt đầu
chúng ta sẽ có thể xóa màu nếu như
mong đáy chưa từng có lớp nào
trường em là nó sẽ theo kỳ nghỉ là kỳ
này chỉ được đăng ký môn đáy thôi và kể
sau khi không được đăng ký
không
mà làm gì có ngày kết thúc rồi nhỉ
đấy là được phê duyệt rồi còn chưa phê
duyệt thì sẽ không thể tạo được ví dụ
thì chúng ta có thể
chỉnh sửa lịch học như là
dời buổi học đi hôm khác hoặc là xóa
luôn cả buổi học đấy
cuối cùng của MU và theo lịch học
như này là
nó sẽ có ngày kết thúc như này và nó sẽ
rời thêm ra phía sau buổi này
có việc bận thì có thể dời lịch học xong
không ngày cuối cùng của ngày kết thúc
Em thử bấm bấm tự động rồi chứ gì
sau ngày cuối
Để anh anh hiểu Anh hiểu ý em nhưng mà
nó không mô tả
thiếu buổi thì cứ tiếp tục học rồi à
nhiều lớp nữa Ví dụ như
sinh viên đấy Hôm đấy học trống ngày hôm
nay ngày hôm giờ không thêm đấy thì nó
sẽ
không ổn cho nên là em không làm em thêm
lịch học
Nên Anh tạo ra phím rời Để ổn định buổi
học
thì có thể thiếu một vài buổi thôi chứ
không thể thiếu nhiều được thiếu dưới
90%
thể
chúng ta có thể điểm danh của một số lớp
học như là
giáo vụ và quản trị viên thì nó sẽ sau
tất cả các lớp ra còn của giảng viên Thì
nó chỉ sau những lớp mà giảng viên dạy
thôi
hoặc giảng viên hoặc là quản trị viên
thì có thể thay đổi thông tin của chính
bản thân
thay đổi mật khẩu
tin ấy thì là tất cả cả giảng viên với
cả sinh viên đều được á thường thì nhé
sẽ là giảng viên là người chính thức
hoặc là người có thể sửa lại thông tin
còn nếu như mà là sinh viên ấy thì chỉ
sửa được một số thông tin cơ bản thôi mà
có những cái khác thì không được mà
là để bảo mật công ty thì xin số lượng
cái danh sách sinh viên Lúc nãy sẽ không
có sẽ thêm user này sẽ không có mật khẩu
cho nên là nó mặc định là ngày sinh thì
để bảo mật thông tin nên em không thêm
vào file Excel đấy Nên là giờ nó thể có
thể thay đổi để cho mỗi sinh viên nó có
mật khẩu khác nhau
cũng như là giảng viên giáo vụ
còn Email Email thì dẫn viên có giáo vụ
và Quản trị có thể thay đổi được ạ
nghĩa là mật khẩu Nói chung là chỉ có
thể thay đổi mật khẩu
có nhiều
quản lý của mình thì là chủ yếu là hỗ
trợ về phần quản lý cho giảng viên và
giáo vụ đúng không còn vì về sinh viên
thì có các chức năng gì để hỗ trợ về
sinh viên để như kiểu đăng ký lớp hay
theo dõi cái
thông tin của mình không Ví dụ các cái
thời khóa biểu của các lịch học hay là
điểm số thì có hỗ trợ shop
bán sinh viên này cũng có thể xem được
những buổi mà mình đã điểm danh
nó sẽ không Mỗi lần điểm danh thì nó sẽ
không báo lên đây thì chúng ta xem được
xóa buổi mà mình điểm danh Ví dụ như
ngày hôm nay là một màu đỏ là sẽ nghĩ là
vãn học và màu xanh là chơi điểm danh và
phần điểm thì sinh viên cũng có thể xem
điểm vào bản thân
Ok
cái phần điểm sẽ theo theo lớp đúng
không nhỉ
sinh viên có thể đăng ký lại của Mông
đấy cho nên là
phần điểm Anh nghĩ là mình lên hiện cái
số điểm lên luôn trong danh sách này thì
sinh viên sẽ dễ theo dõi hơn
em không hiển thị ra cho nó chừng mực
em cũng là cố định rồi đúng không
đấy anh thấy là hình như là sinh viên sẽ
phải liên hệ với giáo vụ ạ
liên qua cái giao diện này luôn thì nó
sẽ tiện hơn bởi mình đã có cái hệ thống
quản lý rồi thì ví dụ đang mở và sinh
viên muốn đăng ký nước nào thì là chỉ có
bấm vào đấy để đăng ký thôi thì có phải
là tiện hơn không nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
thôi đúng không
còn Thì cái phần mà hiện nay là khi mà
tạo lớp lại phải gọi là import cái danh
sách học viên qua cái file Excel à hoặc
là giảng viên hoặc quản trị viên mình có
thể tạo lớp được luôn mà
[âm nhạc]
mà có phần danh sách học viên thì là cái
đấy là phải inbox qua Excel đúng không
Dạ vẫn có thể xem được qua trên hệ thống
Đăng ký lớp học mà nếu mà hỗ trợ lương
giả học viên để đăng ký luôn qua giao
diện Anh nghĩa là đẹp nhất lúc đấy là
học viên đăng ký xong là gần như giảng
viên vào chỉ có việc thôi là được có
danh sách sẵn rồi thì lúc đấy chị có
duyệt lớp thôi
duyệt mở lớp là ok là xong đúng không
chức năng là cũng ok thì chủ yếu là mình
thiết kế làm sao để cho hỗ trợ tối đa
cho cho người dùng học viên giảng viên
để có thể tương tác hệ thống là trực
tiếp thông qua cái cái phần mềm này hết
thay vì là phải một số câu ví dụ là học
viên liên hệ với giảng viên hay là học
học
vụ để để đăng ký thì anh nghĩ là làm
đăng ký trực tiếp luôn và lúc đấy là
đói bụng là chỉ có phê duyệt thôi và mở
lớp thôi
[âm nhạc]
gì không
Ok Cảm ơn nhóm mà em nhé
học Hóa học tính học phí hoặc thêm lịch
thi
của Trang
học một cách dễ dàng hơn giúp điểm danh
và quản lý lịch học tốt hơn giúp tăng độ
chính xác và trong việc xử lý số liệu hỗ
trợ sinh viên hoàn thiện trong học tập
thì lời cuối cùng em cảm ơn đến quý thầy
cô anh chị cùng tất cả mọi người đã lắng
nghe buổi bảo vệ nhóm em hôm nay lời
cuối cùng em xin cảm ơn đến city to
school cũng như anh Long đã có những
khóa học cực kỳ là bổ ích cảm ơn vì
những kiến thức kinh nghiệm mà anh đã
chia sẻ
chúc anh thực hiện được những dự định
trong tương lai cũng như Chúc cho tôi
school ngày càng phát triển mang đến
những bộ học khoa học bổ ích hơn
Xin chào toàn hình như còn một nhóm nữa
của sinh viên nhóm em thì gồm một mình
em Nguyễn Trung Kiên ạ
tiếp theo lý do nhóm em chọn đề tài tăng
khả năng để tăng khả năng quản lý tình
trạng đi học của sinh viên giúp cho việc
điểm danh sinh viên một cách nhanh chóng
và đơn giản không còn thực hiện cái việc
điểm danh thủ cách một cách thủ công ở
trên giấy
thiệu thì công nghệ em áp dụng là pp7
trước tiên là bên giáo vụ sẽ có đăng
nhập đăng xuất quản lý các nguyên quán
chuyên ngành các lớp học và môn và quản
lý giáo viên quản các sinh viên phân
công giảng dạy cho giáo viên tạo tài
khoản cho giáo viên để tham gia điểm
danh và điểm danh tình trạng đi học của
sinh viên giúp cho giáo viên ạ
về phần giáo viên thì cũng có đăng nhập
và đăng xuất giáo viên chỉ có điểm danh
tình trạng đi học của sinh viên theo lớp
đã được giáo vụ phân công ở trên
theo về thiết kế hệ thống sơ đồ thực thể
của nhóm em ạ
về sơ đồ thực thể thì sẽ gồm các thực
thể là
accanic Gear là niên khóa bây giờ chuyên
ngành và
các môn lớp giáo viên học sinh là u dư
và điểm danh ạ về phần liên khóa thì một
viên khóa thì sẽ bao gồm nhiều chuyên
ngành một chuyên ngành sẽ gồm có nhiều
Mun nhiều lớp và nhiều giáo viên đang
dạy tại chuyên ngành đó và một lớp thì
sẽ bao gồm nhiều sinh viên
và mối quan hệ giữa
lớp và giáo viên và môn thì sẽ tạo ra
tôi Simon đây là phân công phân công
giảng dạy
thì một giáo viên thì sẽ được phân công
cho nhiều lần một lớp cũng được phân
công nhiều lần và một môn cũng vậy ạ
Và khi điểm danh thì sẽ điểm danh cho
sinh viên thì từ thực thể sinh viên và
điểm danh thì sẽ mối quan hệ sẽ tạo ra
thêm một bảng là bảng điểm danh chi tiết
đặc điểm danh chi tiết thì sẽ lưu thêm
một thuộc tính nữa là tình trạng điểm
danh ạ
mã môn mã lớp mã giáo viên và các ca học
và ngày đã điểm danh
giáo viên thì sẽ lưu lại mã của giáo
viên Mã môn và mã lớp
sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu
em trình bày cũng ổn rồi anh
họ có chút cái
website Mình ở Simon em đang liên kết
với những
Em nói lại cho mình là phân công giảng
dạy ạ phân công giảng dạy cho giáo viên
giáo viên này sẽ dạy lớp nào và dạy
những môn nào
Tại sao lại có ở kia anh thấy là có hai
cột là cùng là khóa chính và một cột thì
không phải khóa chính tại sao nhỉ Dạ bởi
vì một giáo viên thì có thể sẽ được dạy
nhiều lớp và dạy cho nhiều môn
sao có hai cột là quá trình đâu
Tại sao cột mã lớp với mã khóa chính mà
không thêm cả mã giáo viên Bởi vì khi
một giáo viên thì cũng có thể dạy được
nhiều lớp và nhiều môn em đã nói và khi
thay đổi
và khi phân công giảng dạy cùng lớp và
cùng môn đó thì chọn giáo viên khác thì
sẽ thay đổi lại Giáo viên đã dạy đã phân
công chức đó
dạy đúng không
satos để làm gì nhỉ cột status là để lưu
lại tình trạng đi học của sinh viên ạ ví
dụ như là đi học nghỉ học hoặc là có
phép vậy ạ
Thuê cải lương thời gian ở đâu em nhỉ
Em không lưu lại thời gian ạ
Thế thì biết điểm danh cho sinh viên này
lúc nào
bảng điểm danh thì có lưu lại ngày đã
điểm danh rồi
các thứ em cũng có lưu theo ca là ví dụ
ca sáng hoặc các chiều và ngày chứ không
lưu theo thời gian chính xác
bên giao diện này em cũng không có gì ạ
Vào quản lý sinh viên thì sẽ có xem được
hết các thông tin của sinh viên đã nhập
mà ví dụ muốn thêm một số lượng sinh
viên lớn từ file Excel
báo thành công và tải trang thì thấy sự
thay đổi
điểm danh sinh viên thì sẽ có chọn các
khóa và khi chọn khóa thì sẽ lấy ra các
chuyên ngành thuộc khóa đó khi chọn
chuyên ngành xong cũng sẽ lấy ra các lớp
và các môn thuộc chuyên ngành
là có thể điểm danh hộ cho giáo viên nên
có thể chọn được ngày có thể chọn được
ngày hiện tại và ngày quá khứ ạ Chứ khi
chọn ngày trong tương lai thì sẽ không
điểm danh được à
tình trạng đi học thì em để mặc định em
sẽ tích vào đi học và đây có thể tùy
chỉnh
khi bấm điểm danh thì sẽ hiển thị thông
báo điểm danh thành công như thế này ạ
nào với bạn có thể nói lại cho mình được
kiểu ví dụ điểm danh là giảng viên Ấn
điểm danh như thế nào hay là sinh viên
phải tích hay là hiện đại loại là như
thế
khi điểm danh khi giáo vụ đăng nhập vào
phần mềm thì sẽ bấm vào điểm danh và sau
đó sẽ chọn các khóa
như này ạ khóa chọn chuyên ngành chọn
lớp và chọn mua
khi chọn xong thì sẽ hiển thị ra danh
sách sinh viên đã xin các sinh viên
thuộc những cái lớp mà đã chọn đó
nên khi chọn lại thì sẽ lấy ra cái ngày
điểm danh gần nhất
em Vios ở Bắc Ninh chưa có thể bởi vì
anh cho tương lai
sang bên phân công giảng dạy Không giảng
dạy
khi bấm phân công giảng dạy thì cũng sẽ
chọn các chuyên ngành chọn là chọn khóa
được chuyên ngành chọn giáo viên lớp ở
đây thì do có thể một giáo viên có thể
dạy cho nhiều lớp và nhiều môn nên có
thể chọn được nhiều như thế này ạ
hiển thị thông báo thành công và sẽ lấy
lại cái khóa và chuyên ngành vừa phân
công mà mình có thể chọn tiếp giáo viên
để phân công giảng dạy để tránh gây khó
chịu khi mà cứ phải load lại trang phải
cho lại từ đầu
xong thì có thể giáo có thể tạo tài
khoản cho những giáo viên Mình vừa phân
công giảng dạy Ví dụ như này
như thế này ạ giáo viên thì em chỉ làm
mỗi điểm danh thì ở phần giáo viên thì
sẽ chọn được những cái lớp mà những môn
đã được giáo vụ phân công như vừa nãy ạ
viên thuộc lớp mà giáo vụ phân công ngay
điểm danh thì em để mặc định là ngày
hiện tại
đi học như này để bấm điểm danh ạ
kia rồi nhưng mà không có không có lịch
sử nhỉ Không xem lại được Quá Khứ hay
chỉnh sửa lại
em không đủ thời gian để làm lịch sử
điểm danh anh
một Mới điểm danh cơ bản này đúng không
Cũng không Không có gì thêm cả
ngoài tính năng điểm danh phân công ra
thì anh thấy à bộ mới chỉ dừng lại ở xem
thử Xóa cũng có thêm tí import sinh viên
nhưng mà chưa có thống kê này cũng như
là chưa có những cái tính năng kiểu tùy
biến sâu hơn nhỉ giả vờ sinh viên này
thì liệt kê hết cho tất cả sinh viên
được ra là nó hơi bị nhiều Bây giờ tìm
kiếm thì tìm kiếm nhau tên sinh viên
thôi ạ Đấy thì nó không đủ bởi vì em
sinh viên em nhiều lắm Thực ra
nếu như mà tìm bằng tên sinh viên ý thì
tại sao không tìm bảng mã sinh viên cho
nó tiện hơn ý Bởi vì rất là nhiều sinh
viên cùng họ ở cùng tên hoặc là kiểu tên
giống nhau ý thì thay vì tìm gõ tên thì
mình có thể dùng bằng
số báo danh được mà học mã sinh viên ấy
thì như thể có dễ hơn không
em chỉ làm là tìm kiếm theo tên
giờ vẫn chắc là sinh viên em có rất
nhiều có 1.000 sinh viên làm chuyện
nhiều bạn đã tốt nghiệp rồi mình không
cần quan tâm gì đấy Chẳng hạn đấy thì
mình phải lọc theo khóa Hay là theo lớp
gì đó nữa thì nó ổn hơn
mấy cái cơ bản thôi còn tính năng gì em
muốn nói nữa không nhỉ
thêm bình thường không
Tại em không đủ thời gian nên em chỉ làm
em chỉ làm được điểm danh còn chưa làm
được thống kê ạ
bước là input và Project là xử lý thì
còn chưa có output kiểu dạng là để cho
kiểu tiện cho người dùng nó lắm Ok về
mở rộng thì em cũng sẽ làm thêm phần
quản lý điểm cho sinh viên Thống kê tình
trạng đi học của từng sinh viên ví dụ
như là sinh viên này đi muộn bao nhiêu
buổi và nghỉ bao nhiêu buổi lịch sử điểm
danh theo từng lớp và từng môn nhanh của
nó và phân công lịch học chi tiết ví dụ
như là
tuần này Hôm nào hôm nào học môn nào ạ
Hiện tại thì em chỉ làm điểm danh theo
chuẩn ngày đi
Ok Cảm ơn nhóm của em nhé
[âm nhạc]
không
kiểu ở đây để biết được đang nói thì
thấy bạn ấy có nhấp nhô thì
đồng hồ trong thời gian bạn ấy chỉnh sửa
cố thì nhóm tiếp theo
Hôm nay chắc không bảo vệ không bảo vệ
rồi
buổi hôm sau Thành Long với bạn đấy bảo
vệ được không nhỉ Bữa nay chắc là cũng
hơn video của tận hai tiếng 40 phút rồi
thì đầu tiên là mình
xin cảm ơn em xin cảm ơn anh Hải
buổi hôm nay
đây là sếp của tôi và kiểu cũng cho các
bạn biết được là là kiểu khí dân công
nghệ kiểu dân kỹ thuật kiểu phản biện nó
phải như thế nào về thực tế nó như thế
nào Người thật việc thật đúng không ạ
bạn ấy thấy ứng cử viên nào hôm nay tiềm
năng thì bạn có thể inbox riêng sau và
cảm thấy Xuân nữa thầy Xuân cũng dạy ở
trong school
buổi hôm nay tính ra là mình thấy là rất
thành công các nhóm đều đã đều đã hiểu
được là mình
mình phải làm gì mình cần phải làm gì có
đủ thứ
và kiểu dạng Tuy là mình học online thôi
nhưng các bạn cũng đã tỏ bỏ ra rất nhiều
thời gian để và rất nhiều gọi chưa Sáng
mọi thứ cho nó có thể mình làm ra được
một cái sản phẩm rất là hoàn thiện hoàn
thiện ở đây là là có thể đem đi ứng dụng
được luôn chứ không phải là kiểu chỉ
mang tính chất demo nữa thì
chắc là sau buổi hôm nay đi cha mình sẽ
inbox riêng một vài bạn tiềm năng boss
hết để mà xem
để xem các bạn có thể cân nhắc việc
đi thực tập bên tôi chẳng hạn
là dài rồi mình sẽ tạm kết thúc ở đây
còn hai nhóm hay hai bạn kia chắc là
mình sẽ bảo vệ riêng chắc cũng được đúng
không ạ
xin phép chào mọi người ạ